هذا وقال الناطق العسكري باسم كتائب
القسام ابو عبيده ان مقاتلي القسام تمكنوا
خلال الاسبوع الماضي من تدمير 2ت اليه
عسكريه اسرائيليه كليا او جزئيا كما
اجهزوا على 22 جنديا اسرائيليا من نقطه
الصفر بالاضافه لايقاع عشرات بين قتيل
وجريح في
5 مهمه عسكريه مختلفه تم خلالها استهداف
القوات المتوه بالقذائف والعبوات المضاده
للتحصينات والافراد والاسلحه الرشاشه
واسلحه القنص واضاف ابو عبيده ان عناصر
القسام نسفوا منزلا وفجروا اربعه مداخل
انفاق وحقل الغام في جنود العدو
الاسرائيلي واطلقوا صاروخ ارض جو تجاه
مروحيه في سماء القطاع كما اسقط مقاتل
القسام وفق ابو عبيده طائره استطلاع
اسرائيليه من طراز هرمز 900 واستولوا على
طائره استطلاع من طراز سكاي لارك وطائرتي
درون قال ابو عبيده ايضا ان مقاتل القسام
وجهوا رشقه صاروخيه مكثفه نحو تل ابيب
ومحيطها ودكوا مقار وغرف القياده
الميدانيه والحشود العسكريه الاسرائيليه
بقذائف الهاون والصواريخ قصيره المدى في
كل محاور
القتال